- Chander voila I'll be presenting on
financial data fields
hi my name is Fahim Chander voila I work
for Wolfram Thoms my manager and I'll be
talking about financial data feeds and
Wolfram language and if we are going to
go through the new services we have done
some new work with existing
functionality and that's what we are
discussing um so it's a nice thing that
it tells you it's a text cell alright
we'll get on with it
so Wolfram has a Wolfram finance
platform which is built on our existing
technology you can learn about it by
going to the website it has some support
attached to it extra support attached to
it and it also has some built in CUDA
functionality that is exposed only on
this platform so there is a kind of a
search but it is Wolfram language from
top to bottom just with extra
functionality that might be for
particular people niche folks ok I'll
probably not go to the website right now
but you can google it
so with Wolfram language you have built
in financial data you have access to it
and the service we use is X ignite and
that is through Wolfram Alpha so here's
a small example so if I want the last
price for Microsoft it will give me with
a quantity and the date attached to it
then what stuff that you can ask for
from within the language is let's look
at what properties we can ask for so you
could ask for 200-day average and so on
and the number of property is that we
support at the moment is 73 now
obviously there's a pointed out and
we'll get to that so the limitations
when you get it from the buildin and
functionality you get 15 minutes delay
data there is no real-time data and
there are for your properties that you
might get so there's like how many
people that are in the companies stuff
like that is not available now I'm going
to switch gears and talk a little bit
about services now in Wolfram language
we have a way to connect to external
services and the way we do that is we
connect you here's an example with
pubchem this is a data service for
chemistry and I can evaluate this and I
get a data set from external source
here's X Sigma here as it is top cam and
so the new stuff is that to do it
asynchronously and you can do that by
doing a service sub mat of a service
request it's exactly what I evaluated
previously and here's a callback
function basically what it says is when
I get the data just put it in the
variable response or RESP and then if I
can evaluate this and
okay so that's how we interact with
external services within the language so
we've always had since the release of
Wolfram finance platform Bloomberg link
and just a small background of which it
used to be built on if you're really
Wolfram language you know a little bit
intricacy over it it was built on math
link and it had some limitations but we
rewrote it to give you more access and
more flexibility to do things and I'll
be talking about connecting to the
terminal and other stuff that was
mentioned so to connect to it you just
you service kind of Bloomberg terminal
and you connect to it there's a data
directory connection and host is kind of
interesting because it's localhost it's
not remote its local what's going on
Bloomberg is very cagey about the data
so what happens is you need an external
Bloomberg terminal installed on your
machine that talks to the Bloomberg
servers and your service talks to the
terminal on the localhost at that
particular port so once you connect to
the service you can ask bunch of stuff
and here's an example with Bloomberg
terminal and I'm asking for MSFT US
equity px loss bid and ask now these are
not Wolfram names px loss bed
ask they are provided to you by
Bloomberg servers and there you have it
so you can evaluate and because it's
built on entity you get some nice
decorations over at Microsoft as an
association which might be a bit more
verbose
and these are some of the properties
that you can actually get from Bloomberg
now obviously it's not all the
information in the entity property
itself because some of these properties
might not be associated with equity
market or commodity market like I don't
think is pension active members is
related to microsoft equity in general
so how many properties does Bloomberg
provide fifty thousand nine hundred and
twelve to be exact and compared to
wolfram built n dot seventy three so a
little bit more you can also get
historical data using the entity
language yes so here's and when you use
the entity framework you get a time
series immediately and you have a nice
plot now the good thing about the entity
interface it's very easy to write for
example the date notation is rather nice
this is year to day data and you just
give it a span and one week is the
interval between the data points and you
can ask for very very fine data also
here's an example with all the trades
that happen unless the tick data every
code that came in is presented and
that's an event stories instead of a
time series because multiple treats can
happen at the same time so and this is
what it kind of looks like so at second
one these were the sizes and the values
at which the shares were traded
now I kind of want to modify this this
is just playing five minute data these
were all the trades that happened so how
many events were there ten thousand nine
hundred and thirty-two and I'm only
interested in the volume adding up all
the sizes that's giving me that two
three seven zero five two for a bigger
number and you can quickly do a small
histogram oh wait okay
I'm going to those numbers are kind of
I'll get to why I was doing all bunch of
arithmetic in just a moment then you can
get market bar data this is open high
low close values so though here the
property is entered a bars and then I
have qualifier data object 5-minute is
the bar length
and we have some tools to visualize data
and so here's a trading chart
thus the candles I think it's called the
candlestick chart but there's your
information then I can ask for bar data
values Oh
so this is a different request but I'm
looking at the first five minutes and
these numbers match with the tick data
that we received from Bloomberg so they
are doing bunch of stuff aggregating it
and then giving it to you in market data
request which also you can get using
take data it's always good to match
thing just to make sure things are
working okay and so just an entity stuff
but entities framework has certain
limitations as to how do you give
options to you want to have a gap fold
bar you want to get detail for the
weekends also or put it as missing so
entity framework has a bit of limitation
and that's syntax and probably users
would like that so there is a service
interface for it and this is basically
all the stuff that I just did using
entity framework I can do with service
execute so it's a little bit lower level
API and Wolfram language and here I'm
asking for Twitter sentiment I want to
know what Twitter sentiment means I
don't know what that number is so I can
get the documentation for it
and we also provide languages because
Bloomberg does so you can ask for
documentation and your favorite language
so that's a bit small example and here's
a historical data and this needs to be
no no it's just wrong variable
right and here we don't actually make a
time series for you because we you might
just be interested in the prices if it's
up to the user to do whatever they want
but nonetheless it is easy to get
dateless plot and constructing a time
series offered without a whole lot of
juggling with data and writing
complicated code for read here's
[Music]
take date Oh which is exactly what we
saw but not as a time series but as just
raw data over here and same with here
I'm only getting two data points yeah
and the number is you get the idea so
that's the service interface for
Bloomberg now some requests do take a
while and so you might want to say if
you were I I suspect nobody has ever use
of Bloomberg Langkawi has anyone ever
used Bloomberg link over here oh okay
excellent so in previous versions you
would start the user interface and you
would see a bunch of progress bar then
you would get the market data Explorer
and it will block and you would wait and
things would happen so it was fetching
the feel less to populate and I'm going
to do this and so it starts to task
object and we are fetching
asynchronously and you don't have to
block the kernel you can actually keep
doing it in it's not taking bunch of
resources away from you so this wasn't
possible in previous version now well
that is running I can actually get live
data as I'm getting other requests
because internally it is actually
asynchronous mind you while you're
processing that probably wouldn't be
asynchronous because then you'll be
blocking the kernel what I mean by that
is if your function was heavy and that
did a lot of stuff then you would
actually be blocking
for quite some time now here's a market
bar subscription so as the marketer is
going on we can get all I'm doing as I
get the data and I will show you what it
all means and just a second
so here's a live data for Microsoft and
as that is happening I am also attaching
that's to and I can go back and fetch
the stuff again oh we oh yeah that is
live but in our subscription that is 15
minutes delayed so it's a 15-mile a
delayed stream but your subscription
might be allowing you to get actual live
data yes yes you you can tie it but I
don't want to have a bunch of dynamics
in my presentation just to make things a
little bit simpler but give you guys the
idea of this so now I'm going to so that
was the demo for Bloomberg Reuters is
the new service and this is a bit of a
shorter version and this is how you
connect to the service for Reuters and
you see a bunch of stuff over here what
does it all mean
Reuters gives you a VPN box that you
connect to it's a physical box so all
this stuff interface that means on my
computer at Wolfram there is a port and
that's the address of that Ethernet port
the host is also 1 9 mm using the
reuters using the VPN and whatnot and
and once you are able to connect it will
give you some login exception method so
there's a service object representing
that and then it will work with entity
lookup so here I am asking for ask price
for Microsoft maybe I can do
yeah so again once you connect to the
service you can start going doing entity
value lookups and Reuters provides view
with 15,000 properties and what do they
look like they look something similar to
Bloomberg but not quite and fewer of
those and has a random sample forward
and there is obviously a service
interface for this service execute and
this will give me a bunch of stuff that
comes out from Reuters
okay now Bloomberg data license this is
a pretty interesting service because I
wonder if I Bloomberg folks talked to us
and they say this is very good so I'm
going to say this is very good the idea
is that the licensing of it is much
easier and what that means is that
anybody at Wolfram can use this with
Bloomberg terminal only I can use it
it's hard to test when only I can use
Bloomberg terminal so Stephan who is the
QA he has to take up my machine or he
has to take up my desk when he has to
test this stuff with Bloomberg terminal
okay and this is how you connect to it
there's a data dictionary over here
which you can download this allows you
access to more properties and you have
entity interface for it now previously I
was doing something I was evaluating it
live
but right now not right now not with the
service and we'll get back to it why
that is and how many properties does it
have last jelica so this one has 37,000
that we know off that they tell us about
these there are a dozen random samples
of those and it has a service interface
and I can do service execute and get the
data rather quickly and historical data
also available okay well I'm going to
have to skip this example because I just
deployed the service and that means it's
going to take a couple of minutes to
actually see it but thankfully the time
Siri seems to be this is 20 years of
data from Apple and it is very verbose
actually you can get thick data for a
particular entity for multiple years so
you can be do a whole lot of analysis
with this he has a get course example I
can create a request I can execute the
request and it gives me an event series
this might change actually we might have
give you the data and this will give you
trade bed ask all the events that's why
it's called all codes and you might see
the names are a bit odd get all cows
codes get data service connect and
services are closer to the API that we
use so it gives you really a close we
want to bridge the gap between actual
API and what we allow you to
have over here so there's not a whole
lot of decoration about these things and
here I can get the I don't know what a
zou and equity is usually I forget but I
think it will give me that company oh I
know the address of it that's in
Tennessee I don't know what Dumba deta
license allows you to do because it's a
slow service it takes a couple minutes
to get the data you can actually deploy
the service on to the bloomberg's
servers and schedule it so here I have a
request which is a couple of fields and
then I'm going to do a schedule tasks
weekly so I want these big data points
for azio every week and I can just
deploy it and as on the Bloomberg
service is there around it says it's
data is not yet available and but it
kind of gives you because otherwise it
will run after a week so you don't know
what goes on so it gives you a small
message saying that it's been okay is
deployed and this is how you can get the
tasks you might deploy the tasks and
then you might not know what tasks you
have deployed so so for me is 179 tasks
that I have deployed when I was testing
this stuff and you can redeploy the
tasks
and so I did get tasks let me just show
you what tasks actually looks like the
front end is taking long but these are
the stalls that I have deployed and the
response ID and all of that information
so because you're not going to most most
people don't have their kernel running
for multiple weeks at the same time so I
think that's that will be useful okay so
the limitations of Bloomberg data
license it's slow over there just an
example of how long it took me to get a
time series for twenty years it took
hundred and thirteen seconds why does it
take so long well this is what's
happening when you do this it goes you
submit that I want twenty years of data
Bloomberg at the request and it gives
you a response ID would that response ID
you query like have you got the data it
usually takes a minute or two it's not
it's not processing it's not doing
anything
the code just blocks and keeps on asking
after every 50 seconds or whatnot
whatever I have coded and it blocks for
that time and once it has it gives you
either the error message of something
that's gone wrong or usually if it's an
error it will give you that a much
quicker and it has no streaming marker
data but the licensing is very nice so
in the end new services coming to WFP
wolfram finance platform or reuters
Bloomberg terminal new interface and
Bloomberg data license Bloomberg data
license
unlike Bloomberg terminal will work on
any platform that is Mac Linux and
windows then the new interfaces we are
allowing our services to hook into or
entity framework service framework
and we are also giving access to
asynchronous operations when is this
stuff going to be out WFP 3 . Oh soon
after the release of 12 dotto
Mathematica and if you are interested in
pre-release I think that was a bit of a
talk about customers wanting their hands
on the stuff and there might be a
pre-release program so you'll have to
talk to the right people for that